ministre de l'intérieur monsieur gérald
darmanin savez la parole monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
le président de la république et le
premier ministre m'ont fait confiance
avec marlène schiappa qui travaille
auprès de moi pour continuer à rétablir
la sécurité des français pour
accompagner bien sûr le travail des
services publics intermédiaire du corps
préfectoral pour rendre respect écoute à
nos forces de l'ordre mais également
bien sûr pour lutter contre ce que le
président de la république dans son
discours a qualifié de séparatisme et
oui l'islam politique est un ennemi
mortel pour la république
oui il faut combattre toute forme de
communautarisme mais il me semble madame
que les mises intérieure est également
le ministre des cultes et qu'en france
est citée ne veut pas dire la négation
de cette liberté des cultes et il me
semble que vos propos sont un petit peu
caricatural tout en étant très ferme
caricaturaux
je vous suivez
madame mon grand-père prier allah et
porter l'uniforme de la république
il m'a semblé que bien des tirailleurs
algériens et bien des supplétifs aux par
ailleurs tout en priant pour leur
religion défendu les valeurs de la
république
alors oui oui à la liberté de culte non
à la caricature non à l'islamisme
politique où il ya des français quelle
que soit leur couleur de peau quelle que
soit leur religion
madame si nous pouvions discuter de ce
qui fait nation c'est-à-dire la
marseillaise la culture la langue notre
drapeau ai pas trouvés sont des
caricatures
vous avez eu la gentillesse de me citer
vous avez la gentillesse le site et vous
verrez madame que je suis très fier de
l'assimilation française mon premier
prénom à gérald mon deuxième prénom et
moussa et grâce au président de la
république et grâce à ceux qui m'ont
accompagné
je suis très fier d'être mise de la
république percée
[Applaudissements]